التحديد النووي الروسيه يشير الى احتمال
حصولي ضربه نوويه كهرومغناطيسيه تدمر
المعدات الدفاعيه التي نشرها الناتو في
اوكرانيا وتعطل الدوائر الكهربائيه بشكل
كبير وفق ما كشفه تقرير لصحيفه
البريطانيه واطلاق مثل هذا السلاح فوق
اوكرانيا
ايضا لانظمه حرب المعلومات فكره النبضات
الكهرومغناطيسيه النوويه الصغيره مثل هذه
تنشرها بسهوله على ارتفاعات عاليه بواسطه
صواريخ كروز الروسيه زيركون التي تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت ويمكن للتاثيرات
الكهرومغناطيسيه المتبقيه للضربه ان تدمر
90 بالمئه من الاقمار الصناعيه فوق
المنطقه المنكوبه في غضون ثلاثه اشهر ولكن
ما هي القنبله
الكهرومغناطيسيه هي سلاح تهدف الى تعطيل
الاجهزه الالكترونيه من خلال النبضه
المغناطيسيه الكهربائيه الكبرى التي
يمكنها التداخل مع الاجهزه الكهربائيه
والالكترونيه ونظم تشغيلهم لالحاق اضرار
فيهم واصابتهم بالتلف وعاده ما تكون
اثارها لا تتجاوز 10 كلم من الانفجار اذا
لم تكن مقترنه بقنبله نوويه وان تكون
مصممه خصيصا لانتاج هذه النبضات
الكهرومغناطيسيه الهائله تعتمد جميع
المعدات الدفاعيه التي نشرها حلفاء الناتو
في اوكرانيا مثل اجهزه الراديو ونظام
تحديد المواقع العالمي والطائرات جي بي اس
والطائرات من دون طيار على الالكترونيات
وفي حال استخدمت روسيا هذه القنبله
الكهرومغناطيسيه سيتعين على اوكرانيا وقت
القتال مؤقتا لاعاده تخزين تراسنتها
المدمر ويمكن لبوتن اعاده بناء قوته
واعاده امدادها والا لا ايه على المناطق
واخلاء سكانها حديثا خلال هجوم الربيع
[موسيقى]